des figurines emblématiques de l'univers
de Star Wars des droïdes et des joueurs
aguerris l'ambiance était galactique
salle Raymond patte notre à Rambouillet
pendant deux jours des compétiteurs se
sont affrontés sur Star Wars légion un
jeu édité par le Guyancourtois asmodé
l'idée c'est que les joueurs vont
s'affronter sur un scénario et sur le
scénario ils vont avoir une mission
réalisée qui peut être qui va être tirée
au hasard par exemple récupérer un otage
au milieu aller récupérer une caisse
pousse chercher des ravitaillements
quelque chose de l'univers de Star Wars
en fait pour l'occasion des joueurs sont
venus des quatre coins de la France mais
aussi de la Belgique et de la Suisse ils
étaient plus de 150 ce qui en a fait le
plus grand tournoi du monde c'est le
plus grand mondial même aux États-Unis
ils ont pas été capables de faire 152
joueurs donc c'est c'est un très très
grand événement français c'est
incroyable qu'on puisse faire ça ici
donc c'est avec des orgas au top
vraiment il y a vraiment rien à dire on
retrouve des copains on est venu à
plusieurs de Saint-Étienne dans une
seule voiture donc on a passé déjà 4 h à
discuter de ça on va repasser 4 heures à
discuter dans la voiture au retour on a
repassé 4 heures au resto hier soir à
parler comme ça c'est vraiment un
week-end un peu hors du temps avec une
ambiance géniale et des belles parties
des belles personnes des belles
figurines voilà c'est super à l'issue de
cette compétition les 8 meilleurs
joueurs se sont qualifiés pour les
championnats du monde qui se tiendront à
Chicago en mars 2024